well I'll just get right into it because
we have a lot to cover but I'm gonna be
talking about hockey analysis and our
from a couple different perspectives so
just real quick background about me I
grew up a Phillies sports fan recently
it was a Wharton undergrad but I
graduated last year and for the last
couple years I was a pretty avid public
hockey analyst but right now I'm a
quantitative analyst for the
Philadelphia Eagles just finished my
first full season they're a very fun
very cool job which I cannot talk about
so but in addition that I love our love
the tidy berths and I still talk about
hockey from time to time which is what
this is about
and yeah my our credentials is that I
make fun of Python on the internet
sometimes so real quick what is hockey
the best way I can describe it violent
soccer on ice so you have five skaters a
goalie 60 minutes to try to get more
goals than the other team I think it's
very fast-paced very exciting and it
always feels like a goal can be scored
at any time so when I watch hockey I
feel nervous
um if my favorite team Philadelphia
Flyers is losing I'm like there's no way
the other team is gonna blow this lead
if they're winning them like they are
certainly gonna blow this lead but I'm
often wrong about things and I trust
data so I figured we can dig into some
NHL play by play data and try to find
out the truth about like blowing leads
and that's a more general problem which
we can talk about in terms of win
probability so money puck is a website
friend by Peter Tanner that posts and
updated csv of shot data really any
event in the play-by-play for every
season including the most recent one
2018-2019 which we can access directly
in our just threw up some code up there
i'm gonna post it later but if you run
that you will get every event from every
game in the last season which i think is
pretty cool and then let's talk about
the tidy verse so we see a lot of our
favorite verbs that there are some
filters some mutates but essentially all
I'm doing is taking this play-by-play
data keeping all the goals because again
we're talking about leads & Win
Probability
and then making sure i'm keeping track
of like the running tally of the goals
for home
the home team and the away team in each
game and just for ease of use I'm gonna
filter out overtime games so I'm just
limiting it to games that end in 60
minutes and then so this is what it
looks like now if you just use the view
command check it out this is the second
game of the season the first game ended
in overtime but it's Boston at
Washington and we can see a Boston did
not have a good time they lost seven
zero and these are all seven goals and
the time stamps for them in seconds for
the Washington Capitals and the next
thing we can do is use expand from tied
ER which like I said is the MVP of this
code so what it can do is just expand
each game so we have a row for every
single second instead of just the goals
and then we can join in the goal
information and then fill in the score
lines for all of those intermediate
periods where there wasn't a goal scored
but we know what the score is and we
know what the lead is make sure every
game start 0-0 and then for every second
of the game calculate the lead of the
leading team and then whether or not
that team actually went on to win the
game and that's that this is what it
looks like now so again much bigger so
this is just a tiny snapshot of that
same game I showed you earlier from like
the nineteen through twenty nine seconds
and we can see once Washington scores
their first goal they get a 1 and home
goals and we also see that the lead
column goes to one goal and that the
indicator for whether the leading team
won and so being one because Washington
did end up winning the game we can use
this to just check out some empirical
probabilities based on the lead based on
the time left in the game how often did
the leading team actually end up winning
the game and so this is cool I love
using GD plots I'm a fan of this we can
see that in general it makes sense that
having a bigger lead is definitely
better but there's a lot of you know ups
and downs because again these are just
empirical probabilities and especially
at the very beginning of the game we
don't have a lot of observations of gay
that like we're like 3-0 within like a
minute you know that's very unlikely so
that's why at the beginning of the game
it's kind of all over the place so I
found this a little bit unsatisfying
because I think there should probably be
monotonic and fairly smooth
relationships between the time left in
the game and the probability of winning
given that you have a lead because it
feels better to be up one goal with like
20 minutes left in the game then you
know 25 minutes because basically your
opponent has more time to maybe make up
that lead and you know I fit like a GM
smooth through those empirical
probabilities but that doesn't really
fix that problem it's more specific than
that
so I have one weird hack to ensure
monotonicity and I did it this way
because I love telling people that
actually boosts has really easy to
implement monotone constraints that can
fix that problem essentially so let's
start modeling let's say okay let's get
the probability of winning the game
based on the lead you have in the time
with all this data that we've collected
and we don't really mind getting as
close as possible to like the empirical
percentages as long as we have these
constraints that a larger lead is always
better so we're gonna say you're more
likely to win if you have a two goal
lead versus one goal lead and being
later in the game given that you have a
lead is better because the opponent has
less time to make that up
so as I mentioned having a really small
learning rate would normally over fit to
hell and back but with these constraints
we don't have to worry about that as
much so this is what it looks like after
we model this problem essentially but I
honestly think about it it is closer to
smoothing and you can see that again we
have that monotonic relationship because
it's still a tree model it's like me
like super smooth but I think it's good
enough now one of the things we can do
aside from just figuring out that okay
like if the Flyers have a one goal lead
at the end of the first period which is
1200 seconds into the game they have
like a 70% chance of winning that game I
think that's too high for the Flyers but
whatever
we can do things like find the most
exciting playoff game so I train this
all on regular-season so one of the
things we can do is identify a team in
the playoffs that had a really high win
probability at one point a really low
win probability at one point and see the
disparity there and this turns out to be
actually a very famous game in this
postseason which was the first game the
first round for Columbus and Tampa Tampa
was the best team of the league by some
margin Columbus was the eighth seed
Columbus ended up sweeping Tampa so they
won all four the first games just it was
completely shocking and in the first
game itself
Tampa got to a three goal lead by the
end of the first period and everyone
thought ok this series is completely
over but then Columbus managed to score
four goals after that and win the game
in regulation which was absolutely
shocking so you can see that
Tampa's when probability gets near 100%
after the first period after 20 minutes
and then goes all the way down to zero
so this is cool this is fun but what's
the point
honestly there is one I just I just
wanted to I just wanted to show you guys
some tiny verse code I just wanted to do
a thing it's like not a big deal
it's not really that useful for teams
not everything has to be sometimes it's
just fun to do some exploratory analysis
like this but part of my perspective
because I do work for an NFL team right
now I do have some experience in other
you know topics as they relate to sports
analytics is exploring what teams
actually do find really actionable so
let's switch gears we're going to talk
about the draft so I just have to
explain the draft for anyone who doesn't
know but every year there is a seven
round entry draft for NHL teams so every
team goes up and picks a player a young
player that they would like to be able
to sign in the future so they can end up
playing for their team and so they're
essentially picking the rights to that
player and each team is allocated one
pick per round and for the NHL if a
prospect turns 18 by September 15th of
that year he's eligible to be drafted
and most drafted players are in their
first year
but one in five are actually in their
second or third or fourth so they may be
19 20 21 years old and in a general
sense understanding opposing team draft
tendencies and just general trends and
stuff can be really useful when trying
to make draft decisions because from a
team perspective you want to know what
other teams are gonna do you want to
know if they found any potential and
efficiencies things like that so I have
a little snapshot of the 2012 draft this
is the third round
so picks like 62 to 78 and you can see
that most of these guys are 18 years old
but three of them were 19 and actually
one of those players Shane gasa spear
ended up being a very good defenseman
for the Flyers so they do workout on
occasion last year so before the 2018
draft actually noticed something but
first I had to use our vest which is
amazing to scrape draft data from hockey
reference and what I noticed with
respect to overage prospects is that the
Penguins in the last few years had been
selecting a lot of them recently more so
than any other team in terms of a
percentage of all the picks that they
had and so I thought that was kind of
interesting but I also knew that they
had really late picks so the Penguins
were competing for the Stanley couple
out of the time that means they were
trading a lot of picks so they could get
good players right now so they could be
competitive you know right now and so
they had a lot of late picks and I also
had this hunch that where you are in the
draft influences the likelihood of
selecting over each prospect because
this makes sense because if you have the
first overall pick you want to get the
best guy who like just almost certainly
wasn't available last year and teams
passed on him so you know at the
beginning of the draft people take these
18 year olds who weren't previously
available this new talent and then once
that's exhausted then you start looking
to other avenues for potentially
undervalued picks and we can confirm
this by estimating the likelihood of
selecting over ager based on the pick
that you have by just using a logistic
regression
but so I use the arstan arm package to
fit a logistic regression in a Bayesian
way with weekly informative normal
priors on the coefficients you'll see
why the Bayes ends up being helpful and
so if we do this we essentially for each
pick for each team have a probability
that they would use that pick on an
overage prospect if we just sum this up
for all of the picks for each team we
can get basically an expected value of
all of the prospects of this type that
they are going to select and we can see
how many they actually selected and we
can look at the differential so we can
see that Pittsburgh still comes out on
top so all this means is even after
adjusting for the relative lateness of
their picks in this time period as
compared to other teams they still
picked a lot more you know 19 20 21
year-olds than we would expect so the
tendency still seems pretty real and the
last thing we can do and this is why our
Stan areum was very helpful is that we
can use the posterior simulations
because you know I'm talking about all
these picks but really for the Penguins
that's 21 picks in this time period so
that's a pretty small sample and they
actually selected nine over each
prospects they were expected to select
five-and-a-half you know we could sit
here all day and be like it's nine
really different from five-and-a-half I
don't know whatever but like the way to
sort of be more explicit about that is
to use the posterior simulations of all
of their drafts thousands of times and
see that okay you know just by chance we
would expect that they would draft more
over Agers than they actually did only
about you know six percent of the time
so it's fairly unlikely now if you want
to use like a p-value rule and just like
not care about that anymore you're
welcome to do so but you know I think we
can see all the shades of gray and know
that that still seems pretty compelling
given that it's a very small sample so
and you might be wondering why this
matters
and I mean the the backstory behind this
project is that it's not a very nice
thing to do to tell everyone what a team
may or may not be planning to do I'm a
big flowers fan so I thought it would be
funny to mess with the Penguins like
this and so like I said I did all of
this analysis right before the 2018 NHL
draft and I tweeted out all those graphs
that you saw and I said you know and
then I said all right so if you want to
mess with the Penguins you know take
this type of prospect that they are
known for selecting right before they do
and then the Leafs had the 52nd overall
pick in the draft which was right before
the Penguins first pick and they ended
up taking an overage prospect Sean dersy
which is relatively unlikely at that
point in the draft but I thought it was
very funny and like I'm not gonna so
this is my disclaimer I'm not gonna take
credit for that like they I'm not part
of the Leafs like they have their
reasons for doing things that I have no
idea what they are but you know if like
from a team perspective if you were
interested in a prospect one of the
things that you would like to know is if
any other teams you know in and around
the picks that you have are also
interested in that same prospect so you
can decide when to take him so this is
why a project of this scope is really
helpful for just informing decision
making better from a team perspective
all right so with that thank you so much
for listening I will tweet out the
slides code data for kind of both
perspectives that I showed there on
Twitter I wanted to shout out the two
data sources that I used money puck and
hockey reference for making the state of
really readily and painlessly accessible
to the public which i think is so great
and I didn't talk about this but you
know there are a lot of quote unquote
advanced hockey stats and really
thriving public community for them and
if you're interested at all and all that
I would encourage you to check out any
of these sources that I've
Korsak evolving hockey hockey bez and
natural stat trick to learn more about
just in general what data analysis
hopefully in our can tell you about
hockey all right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]